endet was glaubst willkommen beim ein
video
ja ich habe vor circa ich weiß nicht
zwei monaten also habe ich ein video
rausgehauen
das ihs was mieter nicht tragen sollten
oder dinge die mädchen besser nicht
tragen sollten irgendwie sowas
und das ging auf jeden fall mit der zeit
mega ab ich weiß nicht ob das hat zwar
irgendwie 720.000 klicks oder so hat
auch 26.000 leipzig ganz okay halt
aber halt auch 10.000 displays
zehntausende slice das ist ja nicht
wenig und das ist eigentlich wie viel so
26.000 10.000 ist schon scheiße
eigentlich auf jeden fall kurz vorweg
ich habe jetzt wirklich so eingesehen
dass ist mega falsch waren ein video zu
diesem thema hochzuladen aber ich konnte
das zu diesem zeitpunkt ihnen überhaupt
nicht einschätzen ich hätte mir wirklich
niemals auch nur ansatzweise so
vorstellen können dass das video so
abgeht und das der sonne kasse reaktion
darauf folgt also wie gesagt ich habe
das ganze mit keinem großen
hintergedanken hochgeladen das video
hatte auch nach einem tag irgendwie ganz
normal so 4000 likes oder so 200 discs
ist relativ normal ja und dann wurde es
mit der zeit irgendwie mega kasse klickt
ich meine da kam dann so pro tag 40
tausend klicks neu dazu dass irgendwo
eine woche da hat das 300.000 klicks
gemacht das video und so und mit diesen
klicks war dann auch richtig viele
natürlich auch positive bewertungen
verbunden aber auch richtig viele
negative bewertungen und da dachte ich
mir so ok ich so jetzt so ist es so
schlecht oder woran liegt das ok und das
ist ja so wenn ich jetzt ein video gucke
mir das gefällt dann leid ich dass ich
es einfach wenn ich's dislike dann
schreibe ich meist auch noch ein
kommentar dazu und so ist das bei den
meisten halter bisher gegeben haben auch
passiert wir haben einen kommentar
geschrieben und der war zu 50 prozent
dar ich ich würde einfach so vielleicht
so ich mein okay ihr können schreiben
ist das video blödes aber ihr müsst mich
auch nicht beleidigen ich mein ich habe
auch niemanden eigentlich beleidigt da
dachte ich dann so schon von wegen hey
wieso beleidigt
denn jetzt um davon 6 kommentare da
wurde ich eigentlich nur beleidigt und
die hatten zum teil 2006 oder da war
sein kommentar mädchen sollten das
tragen was sie tragen wollen sehe ich ja
eigentlich auch so der kommentar hatte
dann drei tagen sei es so dass du dachte
ich okay krass wirklich krass ja und ich
habe mir dann irgendwie so dabei gedacht
okay wenn jetzt irgendwo ankommen und
video hochlädt wo er sagen würde ja das
finde ich ein junges cool wenn ihr das
und das tragen oder das finde ich cool
wenn mädchen ist tragen so und nicht das
halt nicht so sehen würde würde ich
sagen okay der hat einen anderen
geschmack ich habe einen anderen
geschmack kein problem ist halt so dann
aber ich fand es wirklich krass und ich
habe das überhaupt nicht erwartet wie
sich manche da so von euch rein
gesteigert haben und sich dann so zum
teil irgendwie fast angegriffen gefühlt
oder vergleich gefühlt haben von mir nur
weil ich sage was ich jetzt ganz gut
findet wenn mädchen das tragen oder
nicht ich meinte bei meinen freunden
oder bei meinen freundinnen oder wenn
ich neue leute kennen der nicht berührt
er jedoch nicht nach ihrem aussehen oder
nach ihnen klamotten was sie tragen das
ist mir scheiß egal hauptsache die
ampullen charakter und man kann nur den
spaß aber es ist mir wirklich scheißegal
was sie tragen ist es doch nur meine
meinung was ich so ganz cool findet wenn
das mädchen anhat oder so fand sich
nicht oder was dann halt irgendwie doch
nicht so cool ist meiner meinung nach
können sofort zum tragen ich mag euch
deswegen noch nicht weniger oder so ich
habe es irgendwie nicht verstanden was
man da so alles rein interpretieren kann
und warum man dann so beleidigen werden
muss ist auch okay ich kann damit
umgehen ist kein problem man wird daher
auch soll es youtuber tagtäglich mit
konfrontiert konfrontiert so okay was
sie vielleicht ein bisschen anders hätte
lösen können wir den titel der klingt
schon etwas hat sowas mädchen nicht
tragen mögen gut kann man so machen muss
man aber nicht als ich aufs eingesehen
aber ich habe doch eigentlich auch nur
so gesagt ja okay das bin ich jetzt ganz
cool und deshalb nicht ich habe es
wirklich nicht verstanden keine ahnung
aber sorry leute ich habe jetzt endlich
eingesehen dass es vielleicht besser
wäre es ein video nicht mehr zu machen
man lernt aus seinen fehlern youtube ist
auch nicht so berechenbar habe ich jetzt
erfahren also neue erfahrungen gesammelt
durch dieses video ist ja auch was
schönes
ansonsten will ich sagen ihr könnt gerne
eure kommen
eure kommentare eure meinung dazu in die
kommentare schreiben würde mich sehr
freuen was ihr davon haltet ihr das
jetzt auch so wie ich oder sagte allofs
das war total scheiße so was kann ich
machen schreibt dass meine kommentare
rein und ja ich bin gerne drüber dann
könnt ihr auch gern noch nach oben da
lassen wenn ihr meine meinung seid oder
was weiß ich was ich genau
keine ahnung ich wünsche dir und
schweden wir sehen uns dann am ehesten
100 und ben